The home stretch, we're
on problem 18.
And this diagram actually looks
like something that this
little tool I'm using is
well-suited to draw.
Let me try-- I'll draw the one
in the back first, so I can do
different colors
and everything.
So I'll do the one in the back
in yellow, and it looks
something like this.
Goes like this, then it switches
over like that.
And then I'll draw the next one,
this orange color, and it
looks something-- no, I'll do
it in a more drastic color.
So it does something
like this.
It goes like this, crosses over,
dips down, then it goes
over again.
And then finally, this last
one, and it looks
something like this.
Crosses over and it goes
like that, very pretty.
Now let me switch to
a smaller-- OK.
Why don't we do white, I
never write in white.
In the figure above--so they
say this is the start.
And this is step 1.
This is step 2.
OK, what is this?
In the figure above, three
wires are braided.
That is, by starting in the
order A, B, C-- OK, so this is
A, B, C-- and then the order
changes to B-- right, because
the yellow line is B-- A, C.
And then we get B, C, A.
Right?
There's just the order of the
strings, left to right.
Or the braids, or the wires.
OK.
That is start with the order A,
B, C, the outer left wire
is brought over wire B, right?
This is brought over wire B, to
the middle position forming
the order shown in step 1.
Than the outer right wire C,
this one, is brought to the
new middle position shown
in step 2, and so on.
Alternately bringing each new
left and each new right wire
to the middle.
At what numbered step does the
braid first repeat the
original order A, B, C?
So what you do is, you first
bring the left over the
middle, then you bring the right
over the middle, then
you bring the left over the
middle, then you bring the
right over the middle.
So at step 3, what
do we have to do?
So step 1 we brought the
left over the middle.
So we went from A, B, C.
You essentially switch the
left and the middle.
And then step 2, you switch
the right and the middle.
So step 3, we switch
B and C again.
Because we're back on
the left-hand side.
So you get C, B, A.
And then step 4, you're
going to switch to
the right-hand side.
Step 3 we switched these two.
Now step 4, we're going
to switch these two.
So you get C, A, B.
Then in step 5, we're back
switched on this side.
So then you get A, C, B.
And then step 6, you're going
to switch to the right-hand
side again.
So you get A, B, C.
So by step 6, we repeat.
So that's choice D.
The hard part here, as far
as I'm concerned, is just
understanding the problem
and their diagram.
And then just seeing the pattern
that you're just
switching the letters.
First you switch the left
and the middle letter.
Then you switch the right
Then you switch the left
and the middle letter.
Then you switch the right
Until you get back to A, B, C.
Next problem.
White I don't think is
colorful enough.
Let me do magenta.
19.
In a set of 11 different
numbers-- they're different--
which of the following
cannot affect the
value of the median?
So it's a set of 11 different
numbers, they're different, so
let's say it's 1 through 11.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11.
That's 11 different numbers.
And in this case, what's
the median?
Well we have 5 on this side, 5--
the median is this, this
is the middle number, right?
6 is the middle number.
Doubling each number-- well,
if you double every number,
the median's going to become
12, so that's not right.
Increasing each number by 10--
once again, if you increase
all of these numbers by 10, this
number's going to be 16,
so you would've changed
the median.
Increasing the smallest
number only.
Well, what if you increase
the smallest number to,
I don't know, 12?
So then this 12 would
go all the way on
the other side, right?
And then the median would move
to 7 because you would have to
have 5 below the median and
5 above the median.
So you can increase that
smallest number.
But if you increase it by a
large enough amount, it kind
of goes into the greater than
the median column, and then
the median would have to
shift to the right.
Try it out, write out the list
from 2 to 12, and then the
median becomes 7.
OK, so we know that choice
B is not right.
Choice C, increasing-- oh no,
that was choice C-- choice D,
decreasing the largest number
only-- well, the same
argument can apply.
We could take the 11 and
decrease it down to, I don't
know, decrease it to 0.
You decrease it to 0, then
that'll-- and you could list
them all out, 0 through 10--
and then the median number
will shift to 5, so that
will change it.
E, increasing the largest
number only.
I can tell you that's the
answer from deductive
reasoning, but if we just take
this 11 and we make it one
billion, does that change the
fact that they're five numbers
larger than 6 and five
numbers less than 6?
Ignore the 0.
Five numbers less than 6?
No.
I can make it into a trillion.
I can change it to any number,
but the fact remains that I
have the same amount of
numbers larger than 6
as I do below 6.
So choice E cannot affect
the value of the median.
E.
Next problem.
OK, something for me to draw.
Let's see, they have a 1/4
circle, so I'll just draw a
big circle, and I'll just
focus on a 1/4 of it.
Close enough.
That looks like a
1/4 of a circle.
They say that-- oh, and there's
a rectangle there too,
fascinating.
So this rectangle in this 1/4
circle, so this rectangle
could look like this.
I know theirs looks taller,
but I think this will do.
And then I think I'm
almost done.
I think I'm there,
I think I can.
And then they shade in some
stuff, so if they shaded it, I
will shade it.
A suitably tasteful color.
OK, so I have shaded what
they have shaded.
And now, what are they saying?
They're saying that this
is R, C, T, B, S, A.
And then they tell us that
is a 90 degree angle.
And then they tell us that this
distance, from here to
here, from all the way to the
top-- so it's essentially the
radius of the circle-- is 6.
The radius of the circle is 6.
In the figure above, arc SBT is
1/4 of a circle with center
R and radius 6.
Fair enough.
If the length plus the width
of rectangle ABCR is 8-- so
the length plus the
width, so ABCR.
So this is the width,
this is the length.
So L plus W is equal to 8.
What is the perimeter of
the shaded region?
Fascinating.
Let's do it step by step.
First we can just figure out
what this part of the
perimeter is.
And that's the easiest
part, right?
Because what's the perimeter
of the whole circle?
Well, it's the circumference
of the whole circle.
Circumference is equal
to 2 pi r.
This is the whole circle
we're talking about.
So that's equal to 2 pi times
6, so that's equal to 12 pi.
This is the circumference of
the whole circle, so the
circumference of this arc, of
this piece, is going to be 1/4
of that, because it's 1/4
of the whole circle.
So it's 1/4 of 12 pi,
so that's 3 pi.
Now, what we need to be able
to figure out is L and W,
because if we can figure out
L and W, we can figure out
everything else about
this circle.
And actually, I'm going to
continue this problem in the
next video, because I think it
might get a little involved,
and I don't want you to
get too confused.
I'll see you in the next video.